[Music]
no one welcome to this video yeah this
video is about setups where black plays
d5 combined with Bishop to f5 usually
they also play C 6 and a 6 or the
typical porn triangle and this is often
the choice of players who play the slap
defense you know they oftentimes play d5
c6 e 6 and then combine it with either
Bishop to g4 or to f5 we have two
dedicated chapters on both of those
setups now with the Bishop f5 setups um
it's um I think it's very interesting to
see that it all boils down to one
particular scenario that we're going to
analyze very thoroughly and this is
white at some moment playing after d4
see for playing Queen to b3 and
detecting the b7 pawn that is something
that I'll show you in a in a moment it's
important to understand that black does
not have to if we put this on the board
and does not have to play Knight f6 c6
Bishop f5 right away they can also a
Bishop f5 right now or start with c6 and
this is not going to be much of a
difference really to us as we're going
to play the same moves basically no
matter what what we are going to do
against Blacks Bishop a5 setups is
always to play g3 next Bishop g2 and
then this is an important thing we are
not going to castle we're going to play
c4 before we castle and this is going to
be really essential for the plane then
later ensue it with Queen to b3 I'm
going to show you this in some minutes
why this is so important to not castle
just very much the key move all the
thing here to remember now and what does
black play him if he doesn't play Knight
I have 66 they can play Bishop a5 Amir
Lim and against this most of the time
the
c4 is recommended I looked at this but I
don't think it is much it's not really
worth to look at this in any big detail
it's not so much of a punishment let's
say compared to g3 so I recommend to
just play g3 and we will get a
completely normal setup yeah you can
analyze the form but I don't really
think it's much better than g3 to be
honest just maybe a little bit better
for white
so just g3 to save some theoretical
workload mm they can start with C 6 and
after g3 Bishop f5 Bishop g2 a 6 they
can delay the development of the night
it's not a big problem for us we're
going to play C 4 anyway again before we
castle and here like we'll probably play
Knight f6 or after 97 Knight c3 play
Knight f6
and there's really not much independent
2 independent moves to look at they
could maybe take on c4 but after 95 we
just get the pawn back with no problem
at all or they could play Bishop takes
b1 and this is something that we should
look at just briefly it is a bad move
but it's just one where to be different
to the scenario with Knight f6 being
played so takes check
you should be too queen a - it was the
idea of Bishop f5 so black is saying I'm
giving up the bishop pair whose I'm
giving up the bishop pair and I'm going
to move the Queen ton of times and then
yeah then see what I mean white is about
three or four tempie up it's it's crazy
now right is better here with many moves
but the best move is to move c5 this is
useful to remember the main point is
that we are completely cutting the Queen
away and I mean like where is it now
going it's very difficult it's only like
a six or something is really difficult
he has to give some yeah space to the
Queen otherwise we will probably trap
with him
so b6 so that the Queen can somehow
retreat after before however we have a
very strong attack for the pawn if black
goes Queen a6 a very powerful
continuation is b5 C takes e4 yeah and
well then blacks play looks a little bit
like yeah I don't know some second-rate
tournament from the nineteen from the
1880s or something but yeah you never
know where you might get it get it off
the board looks like this say we are
threatening Bishop takes but also Bishop
I want to be five and black and I can
resign your Moses is not defensible
it's just that yeah keep in mind they
can take on b1 and give the check it's
not going to be a good for Blanke but
it's something that could theoretically
happen in the absolute majority of cases
black is playing Knight f6 and after g3
plays C 6 and then Bishop f5 that is
most common they can start with Bishop
f5 though and after Bishop g2 try to not
place his six I mean it's very natural
to do so but they can try to delay or
omit to move after for example age six
yeah that is not bad by the way it's not
yet a bad decision see form we see six
it could still become rather mainline
ish you 693 now c6 would transpose to a
mainline that usually would start with
an earlier c6 but black can try to not
do that at all it should be seven but
after this the Queen b3 move is going to
be more annoying than usual there is no
natural Queen b6 reply and after
something like knight c6 castles don't
take on b7 that is an important point
it's after night before like a
threatening basically a perpetual attack
on our queen and this is just a draw we
don't want that so
the castles rook b8 and something like
this white is definitely a little bit
better because black screen side is
under pressure that is not an ideal way
to set up the queenside
black is usually playing a quick c6 to
be ready to play Queen to b6 you know
against Queen b3 if they hear play a six
instead of c6 after C form Bishop e7
again here c6 would be best and
transposed to the main line in in this
kind of position after Knight c3 again
c6 would be main line um if black is
delaying this too long we see six when
b3 gets more powerful but also Knight h4
becomes an option this is getting
particularly interesting if this bishop
has no retreat square on age seven and
if the night is already out because
often after night h4 simply taking on b1
can be an exit strategy but here we will
simply get the better game for example
after Bishop b4 f3 like retreats and we
can take and expand powerfully in the
center this is just going to be very
good for white and for example after c5
b 5 and therefore we have a pretty
substantial advantage yeah in the most
in most cases black will play c6 but
these deviations will sometimes happen
because people just don't know the
theory all that well and they can also
play this and not play c6 and we play
Queen b3 again and now black has to play
this more passive defense with Quincy
aid and something like this is very good
or white this is something that we will
see in the main line as well Nia this
could easily happen if black starts with
c6 e 697 and after Queen b3 plays Queen
c8 has in fact a transposition we have
to mostly really look at c6 based setups
they are by far the best for black and
also the
most most common really so g3 c6 Bishop
g2 and here Bishop f5 is mostly played
they can play h6 but after c4 they will
probably go Bishop f5 for a
transposition if black takes will you
get the pawn back conveniently with a
setup like this black doesn't have any
b5 so we will be able to recapture the
pawn and if we get the pawn back without
any other concession it's going to be a
good advantage for us it's just that
black has given up a central pawn depot
and for a C pawn and this is not
strategically all there great without
any concrete compensation like a
weakness or something like that this
would happen for example in the Slav
ethical Slav mainline where I place a 4
it weakens the before Square um here we
mostly have to look at the move Bishop
f5 of
[Music]
you